>>> I'M JOHN BERN IN LVIV IN
WESTERN UKRAINE.
BRAND-NEW VIDEO JUST INTO CNN.
IS SHOWS A RUSSIAN SHIP, THE
UKRAINIANS SAY, ABLAZE IN THE
PORT CITY OF BERDYANSK.
THIS IS A CITY THAT HAS BEEN
UNDER CONTROL BY RUSSIAN TROOPS.
THIS IS A FIRE AT THE DOCK YARD
UKRAINIANS SAY ABOARD A RUSSIAN
LANDING SHIP, A VESSEL THAT'S
BEEN IN PORT FOR SOME KIND.
A SHIP THAT COULD DELIVER ALL
KINDS OF SUPPLIES TO THE GROUND.
A HUGE FIRE.
SECONDARY EXPLOSIONS.
THERE'S A BIG OIL TANK NEARBY WE
ARE TOLD AND SOME MU FISH SHANS
DEPOTS ABOARD.
I'M JOINED BY CEDRIC LAYTON.
COLONEL, YOU LOOK AT THIS VIDEO
AND YOU HEAR WHAT THE UKRAINIANS
SAY.
THEY HAVE DESTROYED A RUSSIAN
VESSEL IN AN AREA MORE OR LESS
UNDER CONTROL BY THE RUSSIANS.
>> YEAH.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL, JOHN.
THIS IS A 370 FOOT VESSEL, NOT A
SMALL TUGBOAT.
IT'S CALLED THE DORSK.
IT WAS USED TO RESUPPLY RUSSIAN
FORCES SURROUNDING MARIUPOL.
WHAT THE UKRAINIANS ARE DOING IS
ENGAUJING IN VERY GOOD
INTELLIGENCE WORK AND VERY GOOD
SABOTAGE WORK ACTING ON THE
INTELLIGENCE.
APPARENTLY THE RUSSIAN STATE
MEDIA HAD USED FOOTAGE OF THE
BORSK IN PORT AND THEY WERE ABLE
TO GEO LOCATE THAT AND ON THE
BASIS OF THAT ACCORDING TO S